SAL: I'm here with our
exercise guru Ben Eater.
BEN EATER: Thanks Sal.
SAL: And we're looking at your
exploring standard deviation 1
exercise.
And let me think about
what's going on here is.
It says arrange the 13 orange
sample points in the histogram
below.
So these are the orange
points you're talking about.
So the sample standard
deviation is approximately 1.6.
So just so I
understand these, these
are points that are being
sampled from sum distribution?
BEN EATER: Right.
SAL: We get these
points right over here.
And then your module
is automatically
calculating the sample mean.
BEN EATER: Right.
SAL: Which is kind of
the central tendency
of at least these points.
It's estimating the
mean of this population
you're sampling from.
And then also the sample
standard deviation,
which is really kind of a way
to measure on average how far
away they are from
that sample mean.
BEN EATER: Yeah and what
we're trying to do here
is to kind of get a sense
of what that actually means.
So we say the
standard deviation is
1.9, what does that
sort of feel like?
SAL: Right.
It seems clear that the sample
mean it looks like it literally
is the average of these numbers.
BEN EATER: Right, it is.
SAL: And it looks like
if I move this out,
then it moves to the
right a little bit.
But that's just one point.
The mean moves to the right.
The mean I think, it's easier to
have an intuition for the mean.
BEN EATER: A lot of people have
a pretty good sense of it here.
SAL: If stuff
moves to the right,
then the mean
moves to the right.
If we move stuff to
the left, then the mean
moves to the left.
That makes sense.
But the standard
deviation in this case,
we're measuring the
sample standard deviation.
This is a measure of dispersion.
And I say on average in
quotes because it's not
exactly the on average
that we typically--
BEN EATER: And that's kind
of point of this exercise.
It's not kind of exactly
on average, so what is it?
SAL: Right.
But you see that
the further-- so
let's see, the further
the points are spread out,
the wider this sample
standard deviation is.
If I bring the points
closer together,
then the standard deviation
gets smaller and smaller.
If I bring them closer to
the sample mean, as you see
they get tighter and tighter.
So let's see, let's do
the actual exercise.
So arrange the 13
order sample points
so the sample standard
deviation is approximately 1.6.
Right now it's 2.1, so I want
to squeeze things together.
And there's no
right answer here.
I just have to get them in
a way that I'm close to 1.6.
So I want to move things
closer to the sample mean.
And so let's see this one,
so 1 point by itself--
actually just moving
this 1 point--
BEN EATER: Not quite.
SAL: Just that 1 point
didn't quite do the trick.
But I could move more things in.
And it really could be I
could pick another point,
move it closer to the--
BEN EATER: Lots
of ways to do it.
SAL: I'll have a bigger impact
if I move something that's
right now far away and
move that closer in.
BEN EATER: That's right.
SAL: Because right
now that's kind
of taking that-- OK,
that looks right.
1.6, so let me check
my answer, correct.
BEN EATER: Now, look
at this show solution.
SAL: OK, show solution.
The standard
deviation is smaller
if the points are
closer to the mean, yes.
The standard deviation is
larger if the points are more
spread out.
Try removing a point
closer to and further away
from the sample mean to see how
the sample standard deviation.
BEN EATER: So that's
telling us what we just did.
Look at the next step.
SAL: Oh, there's another step.
BEN EATER: And what this
will do is actually show you
different examples
of how to get to 1.6.
So if you click that, it'll
show you maybe a different way.
SAL: Oh, that's neat.
BEN EATER: Now, click it again.
And so what you can see is
there's lots of different ways
to have a sample standard
deviation of 1.6.
And they may look different,
but if you keep clicking that,
you'll kind of see there are
some things in common as far as
how they are grouped
close to the mean.
SAL: And one of the things
I just want to clarify
is you've drawn this
kind of bell curve
with that area
shaded in the back.
That is our estimate of what
the real distribution might
look like based
on the information
we have of the sample.
So if our sample
mean is accurate,
if it really is estimating the
true mean of this population,
then that's what we're
drawing in the middle.
And then we're assuming it's a
normal just kind of bell curve
shape distribution.
So that's what it would look
like based on information
we have.
BEN EATER: Right.
SAL: This is very cool.